[Musica]
e questa è una cucina attrezzata per
fare una buona raccolta differenziata
questo è un rubinetto che ci dice quando
aperto quanta acqua stiamo consumando
questi sono dei contenitori messi su una
spiaggia per fare la raccolta
differenziata con un cartello che ci
dice che nella baia vicina sono stati
già bravissimi hanno già fatto il 70 per
cento
questi sono dei gas di scarico che
quando l'aria ha superato i parametri
negativi del pm10 o legno hicks si
colorano di rosa un orinatoio maschile
con una mosca stampata sulla ceramica un
semaforo giallo e alla fine un
abbonamento per una palestra che si
rinnova automaticamente che cosa sono
tutti questi oggetti tutte queste
suggestioni sono tutti i casi di nagel e
questa è questo il loro comune
denominatore sono cioè oggetti opzioni
parole comunicazioni che ci spingono
verso comportamenti positivi positivi
nelle intenzioni di chi ha progettato il
naso perché il nyse si progetta non
nasce per caso e quindi quella scala che
funziona come un pianoforte aiuta le
persone o meglio le diverte
ad usarla invece che usare la scala
mobile
una cucina ben organizzata per fare
raccolta differenziata spinge anche chi
non ci aveva pensato prima a farla il
rubinetto che ti dice quanta acqua stai
consumando ti porta a chiuderlo quando
proprio non serve il cartello della
raccolta differenziata in spiaggia che
ti dice che quegli altri sono stati
molto bravi
ti spinge ad essere ancora più bravo e
quindi a emulare quel comportamento la
mosca la mosca è stata inserita in un
aeroporto europeo né gli ordinatori
maschili corregge le distrazioni
maschili e riduce del 20 per cento le
spese di pulizia i gas di scarico ma ve
l'immaginate quanto sarebbe divertente
se in una città appena abbiamo superato
le nukes dalle caldaie o dalle
automobili uscisse una polvere rosa
forse ci sentiranno invitati a spegnere
il motore laddove possibile e infine il
semaforo giallo ti dice affrettati
affermati io una mobilità fatta di
semafori rossi sono rossi possono verdi
non riesco ad immaginarla il naso
letteralmente tradotto dall'inglese
significa spinta gentile e chi lascia
sempre libero di non aderire non è mai
obbligatorio ed entra nel linguaggio
dell'economia comportamentale con un
libro di tal re sunstein del 2008 che
viene tradotto in europa ed entra arriva
in europa dopo poco e viene sperimentato
per la prima volta dal governo cameron
nel 2010 che grazie ad un suo
brillantissimo direttore strategico crea
la nagy unit che scommette su maggio e
quindi sulla spinta gentile per lavorare
su temi di grande importanza sociale
come per esempio la lotta alla povertà
io ho cominciato a fare delle
sperimentazioni di nagy circa 20 anni fa
perché avevo chiara una cosa i divieti e
le norme servono ma non sono alle volte
così fondamentali così decisivi
nell'accompagnare i cittadini verso
quella transizione verso l'ecologia
verso la sostenibilità di cui abbiamo
tanto bisogno e che invece andrebbe
fatta attraverso delle tocchi delle
spinte di gentilezza cioè degli
interventi in grado di rendere attraente
quello che stai facendo
lavoravo per una cisco per una
circoscrizione comunale di firenze
80mila abitanti poco meno di questa
città si scopre che il 95 per cento di
quei cittadini per bere comprava acqua
minerale non si fidava dell'acqua di
rubinetto l'acqua di rubinetto aveva una
percezione parità 0
mi chiesero che cosa ci inventiamo
perché l'obiettivo era ridurre i rifiuti
togliere un po di plastica dei
cassonetti e fu lì che mi inventai un
progetto che si chiama quartiere e che
consisteva nel rendere l'acqua di
rubinetto più organoletticamente
attraente e quindi avvicinarla ai
cittadini e aiutarli a fare switch a
passare dalla minerale padre rubinetto
facemmo degli accordi con le pubbliche
con
gli esercizi commerciali riuscimmo a
erogare acqua trattata a prezzi
bassissimi se non gratis come andò a
finire che in meno di un anno
quel 95 per cento era diventato il 56
per cento cioè più di un terzo di quelle
persone aveva scelto finalmente l'acqua
di rubinetto
fu un risultato importante è però va
progettato cioè una spinta gentile serve
progettarla per questo si parla di nagy
design come si progetta una già parole
prodotti da modificare ricordatevi la
mosca il rubinetto opzioni di default
l'abbonamento alla palestra che se si
rinnova automaticamente fa crescere il
numero di iscrizioni è quello il nage
che mi interessa quello che opera nel
mondo della sostenibilità e che riesce
quindi a farci transitare verso
comportamenti sostenibili di cui abbiamo
veramente sempre più bisogno e vi lascio
con un ultimo piccolo racconto che a
proposito dell'importanza del modello
del modello anche che parte dal basso
ci dice quanto una spinta gentile possa
essere potente qui adesso la città e
detroit che negli anni 70 80 e 90
subisce un tracollo economico dato dalla
crisi petrolifera e dal crollo del
mercato dell'auto i ricchi vanno a
vivere fuori i poveri restano sono
peraltro basie perché mangiano cibo
spazzatura e nasce un'associazione che
decide di scommettere sulla
riforestazione urbana di questa città il
che oggi fa sorridere perché quasi tutte
le metropoli europee stanno scommettendo
sugli alberi ma 30 anni fa nel 89 questo
non era assolutamente scontato trovano
soldi trovano migliaia di volontari
riescono a piantumare alberi riescono a
far andare ad insegnare ai ragazzi a
scuola come si coltiva la terra e
diventano talmente bravi che dagli
alberi riescono a fare gli orti e gli
orti significano cibo cibo sicuro e
quindi lavoro e quindi restituzione di
sorrisi che cosa hanno fatto questi
hanno fatto hanno dato la possibilità a
tanti infelici di scegliere tra una
pianta di fragole è una rivoltella e
quelli che hanno scelto la piante di
fragole si sono salvati e che cosa c'è
di più gentile dina piante di fragole
[Applauso]